mit der im cap in den urlaub heute geht
der digitale impfpass an den start er
soll reisen im sommer leichter machen
ein nein aus rom papst franziskus weiß
das angebot von kardinal marx zurück
nach den missbrauchsfällen in der
katholischen kirche zurück zu treten und
rückkehr der riesenflieger in bayern
werden bartgeier ausgewildert 140 jahre
nach ihrem verschwinden
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend schön dass
sie dabei sind wie auch norbert lehmann
für den sport ein schöner von mir wie
viel freiheit und normalität erlauben
die sinkenden corona zahlen der chef des
robert koch-instituts viele spricht von
einem erfreulichen rückgang mahnt aber
zur vorsicht das virus ergreife jede
noch so kleine shops mittlerweile liegen
alle 412 landkreise unter einer sieben
tage incident von 100 nur noch zwölf
landkreise haben einen wert über 50
die bundesweite inzidenz sinkt auf nur
19,3
doch auch die kanzlerin bleibt
zurückhaltend aus berlin daniel putzen
sorge mache der kanzlerin die aggressive
sogenannte data variante des virus
deswegen seien strenge
einreisebeschränkungen gegenüber
großbritannien und in ihnen richtig
damit diese variante auch weiterhin nur
einen kleinen anteil der choren
infektion in deutschland ausmache wir
sind im grunde in einem wettlauf mit dem
impfen
jeder tag den wir eine geringe
nachweisbarkeit dieser variante haben
dass ein guter tag wir sind jetzt bei 25
prozent
der anstieg ist recht langsam im
augenblick und ich hoffe dass das so
bleibt was die impfung von 12 bis 17
jährigen betrifft empfahl die stiko
heute wie erwartet nur jene mit
vorerkrankung zu impfen nach ärztlicher
aufklärung und individuellem wunsch aber
soll sie auch bei andern möglich
unterdessen rügte der rechnungshof heute
das bisherige pandemie management zu
teuer zu lasche kontrollen apotheken
etwa seien mit sechs euro pro maß gilt
deutlich überkompensiert worden
zehn milliarden euro an
ausgleichszahlungen für die
krankenhäuser habe zudem unerwünschte
mitnahmeeffekte eröffnet das robert koch
institut etwa äußerte die vermutung dass
krankenhäuser zum teil zu niedrige
intensivmedizinische behandlungsplätze
meldeten gesundheitsminister sparen
verweist auf die länder die nachweise
über die geschaffenen betten erbringen
müssten
es gab den beschluss von bund und
ländern
die intensiv kapazitäten in deutschland
verdoppeln zu wollen
dann haben wir ins gesetz den ländern
den auftrag gegeben
diese mittel zu verwalten und zuzuweisen
um krankenhäuser oder apotheken in die
pandemie bekämpfung einzubinden müssten
zudem anreize geschaffen werden weil man
sie nicht zwingen könne eine
gratwanderung die laut rechnungshof
jedoch gleich mehrfach misslang
ab heute ist der digitale impfpass zu
haben er soll es einfacher machen im
restaurant theater oder im urlaub zu
belegen dass man vollständig gegen
korona geimpft ist
allerdings braucht es wohl auch hier
eine gewisse geduld mittlerweile haben
knapp 24 prozent der bürger beide
impfungen 47 prozent haben eine spritze
bekommen
sven ricke mit details zum neuen digital
pass die apotheke von marc heudorfer
wird eine der ersten seinen des qr-codes
als digitalen impfnachweis gibt besser
gesagt geben wird dennoch kann der
apotheker aus hamburg nur theoretisch
zeigen was geplant ist im heft und
ausweis zeigen und qr code mitnehmen in
der nacht zum montag erst werden seine
leitungen geschaltet rechner paar
tausend apotheken anfragen und das dann
wieder zurückgespiegelt wird den qr code
kann die korona vanek oder die neue copa
sap speichern friseurin monika schicke
gabor ski hat auf ihrem handy das
gegenstück die kopatschek ab ob der code
allerdings zum besitzer gehört muss sich
selber prüfen wie bei allen anderen
nachweisen oder nachweis apps auch
[Musik]
gemacht trotzdem kostet der prüfvorgang
zeit zeit die im biergarten oder dem
lokal nebenan oft fehlt für die kunden
aber wird vieles einfacher
ab dem ersten juli auch überall in
europa 18 euro bekommen apotheken und
ärzte übrigens für den nachträglich
erstellten im qr code für eine computer
eingabe die zwei bis drei minuten dauert
sie müssen eine vergütung machen die den
aufwand widerspiegelt
möglichst viele der 19.000 apotheken mit
machen sie denn nicht gezwungen als
apotheke mitzumachen manche impfzentren
versenden die qr-codes automatisch per
post in manchen wie in hamburg wird es
ein online portal für den abruf geben
alle zukünftig doppelt geimpften
bekommen den code bei der zweiten
impfung gleich mit am wochenende küren
die grünen offiziell annalena baerbock
zur kanzlerkandidatin und müssen
hinnehmen dass ihre partei und ihre
spitzenkandidatin in umfragen federn
lassen
das erste politbarometer nach dem
wahlsonntag in sachsen anhalt sieht
andere vorn
matthias fornoff guten abend war wind
hat sich an der einschätzung geändert
naja die cdu kann wieder siegen kommt
aus dem rekordtief von mayr aus und
nimmt den schwung aus sachsen anhalt mit
ganz anders die grünen der dämpfer von
magdeburg drückt auch das bundesweite
umfrage ergebnisse
wenn am sonntag bundestagswahl wäre käme
die union auf 28 prozent plus 4
die spd 15 plus 1 die fdp unverändert 11
fdp 10 prozent minus 1 die linke
unverändert 7 die grünen 22 prozent
minus 3 freie wähler unverändert 3
prozent das würde reichen für
schwarz-grün knapp aber auch für eine
grüne ampel mit spd und fdp
er ist aktuell wirklich frisch
kanzleramt wir haben gefragt er eignet
sich eigentlich als kanzler oder
kanzlerin und da sehen wir wenn auch auf
niedrigem niveau
zuwächse bei armin laschet und olaf
scholz im vergleich zum mai die werte
für annalena baerbock dagegen brechen
geradezu ein
nur noch 28 prozent halten sie für
geeignet als kanzlerin vor die wahl
gestellt hätten 59 prozent lieber
laschet 31 der burg im kanzleramt
laschet liegt auch knapp vor stolz im
vergleich mit baerbock hätten 58 prozent
lieber scholz als kanzler
die grünen-spitzenkandidatin erlebt also
nach der anfangseuphorie jetzt
ernüchterung dankeschön matthias fornoff
das ganze politbarometer können sie ab
viertel vor zehn im heute journal sehen
oder
jederzeit online auf zdf heute oder in
unserer nach hessen zum jüngsten fall
einer rechtsextremen chat gruppe unter
polizisten das hat jetzt konsequenzen
das land löst das betroffene
spezialeinsatzkommando auf ermittelt
wird gegen 20 beschuldigte drei davon
sind vorgesetzte die nicht
eingeschritten sein sollen
den übrigen wird vorgeworfen sie hätten
volksverhetzende inhalte ausgetauscht
darunter hitler bilder und hakenkreuze
stefan schlosser berichtet der
innenminister steht unter druck wieder
einmal
heute will er offenbar stärke
demonstrieren und versucht einen
befreiungsschlag nichts könne im
frankfurter sek bleiben wie es war sagte
peter beuth heute das inakzeptable
fehlverhalten gleich mehrerer
mitarbeiter sowie das wegsehen
unmittelbarer vorgesetzter m sek
frankfurt macht für mich dessen
auflösung unumgänglich die aufgedeckten
womöglich strafbewehrten chats zwischen
mitarbeitern des sek sind völlig
inakzeptabel
der neue skandal nur einer von vielen
bei der hessischen polizei in den
vergangenen jahren 20 beamte der
elitetruppe sollen rechtsextremistische
inhalte in einer stadt gruppe
ausgetauscht haben die stimmen die den
rücktritt des innenministers fordern
sind nicht mehr zu überhören
aus meiner sicht ist der erneute fall
eines vorfalls eines rechtsextremen
chats in grund dafür politische
verantwortung zu
in extra geschulten spezialeinheiten wie
dem sek werden nur polizisten mit
längerer berufserfahrung aufgenommen
dass solches fehlverhalten dennoch
vorkommen verwundert experten nicht sind
aber nicht geschult besonders geschult
in interkultureller kompetenz oder
einfühlungsvermögen oder besonders
geschult in rechtsstaatlichkeit diese
schulungen gehen tatsächlich eine andere
richtung nämlich durchsetzungsfähigkeit
belastbarkeit spannungen aushalten da
machen sie wirklich ein sonder punkt
aber nicht in richtung demokratie
festigkeit ob die angekündigten
maßnahmen ein befreiungsschlag sind ist
fraglich für den innenminister ist die
affäre noch nicht ausgestanden
die sache war bis zuletzt höchst
umstritten jetzt bekommt der
inlandsgeheimdienst mehr rechte beim
zugriff auf telekommunikation
künftig soll der verfassungsschutz bei
whatsapp und anderen verschlüsselten
messenger diensten mit lesen dürfen wenn
das im einzelfall angeordnet wird
die opposition viele datenschützer und
presse organisationen lehnen diese
neuregelung ab es war ein paukenschlag
vor knapp einer woche als der münchner
kardinal marx bekanntgab er habe dem
papst seinen rücktritt angeboten
er wolle mit verantwortung übernehmen
für die zitat katastrophe des sexuellen
missbrauchs heute schon die antwort aus
rom
nein der papst lehnt den rücktritt ab
viele sind froh dass marx weiter machen
soll
aber es gibt auch kritik stefan leifert
berichtet
für münchen ist es eine doppelte
überraschung dass die antwort aus rom so
schnell kommt und wie sie ausfällt
das ist meine antwort lieber bruder
schreibt der papst macht weiter so wie
du es vorschlägt aber als erzbischof von
münchen und freising vorgeschlagen hatte
reinhard marx vom amt des erzbischofs
zurückzutreten und sich der seelsorge
und erneuerung der kirche zu widmen das
möge er tun aber als bischof das ist
eine enttäuschung ganz klar kardinal
marx hat ein starkes signal geben wollen
in der letzten woche und dass der papst
so rasch dass zurück weiß zwar nicht in
der form sehr persönlichem stil aber
doch ziemlich klar entwertet diesen
signalen stück weit wie wir sehen die
ablehnung des rücktrittsgesuchs als
stärkung von marcel marx hat den
synodalen weg in deutschland eröffnet
gemeinsam mit dem zentralkomitee
es gibt noch sehr viel zu tun der papst
stellte sich an die seite eines mannes
der nach den missbrauchsskandal nicht
einfach zur tagesordnung übergehen und
die kirche reformieren will
ich werde schreibt marcks in den
nächsten wochen darüber nachdenken wie
wir gemeinsam noch mehr zur erneuerung
der kirche hier in unserem erzbistum und
insgesamt beitragen können mit seiner
entscheidung stärkt papst franziskus die
position von kardinal marx zum einen was
die schonungslose analyse des
missbrauchsskandals anbetrifft zum
anderen aber auch die notwendigkeit von
systemischen reformen die weltkirche
blickt in diesen tagen gebannt nach
münchen und nach rom
die botschaft des papstes von heute ist
vieldeutig ein aufruf zum weiter so aber
ist sie nicht wegen plagiatsvorwürfen um
ihre doktorarbeit war franziska giffey
im mai als bundesfamilienministerin
zurückgetreten
jetzt hat die freie universität berlin
ihr tatsächlich dem titel entzogen
begründung er sei durch täuschung über
die eigenständigkeit ihrer
wissenschaftlichen leistung erworben
worden
die spd politikerin sagte sie bedauere
fehler sie habe die arbeit aber nach
bestem wissen und gewissen verfasst
erstmals seit 20 jahren hat die
kinderarbeit wieder zugenommen 160
millionen minderjährige arbeiten statt
zur schule zu gehen so ein bericht des
un kinderhilfswerks unicef und der welt
arbeitsorganisation ilo grund die große
armut der familie denn viele eltern
sehen sich genötigt wegen weltweiter
lockdown schulschließungen und
ökonomischer zusammenbrüche ihre kinder
arbeiten zu lassen
es ist seine erste auslandsreise als us
präsident joe biden besucht europa erste
station ist großbritannien
dort beginnt morgen der g7 gipfel und
dort zeigte der präsident heute schon
dass er westliche werte und bündnisse
stärken will aber trotzdem auch
gegenüber gastgebern kein blatt vor den
mund nimmt
rt wissen berichtet man sieht es den
beiden gar nicht an aber der gastgeber
wird sich wohl geärgert haben dass sein
gast einfach so partei ergreift joe
biden hatte sich hinter das nordirland
abkommen zwischen der eu und der
britischen regierung gestellt dieser
zusatz zum rexit regelt den grenzverkehr
zwischen irland und nordirland liberal
boris johnson verweigert die umsetzung
immerhin in einem sind sie heute einig
die atlantische charakter hier in der
vitrine zu erneuern die einst 1941
roosevelt und churchill unterschrieben
hatten als fahrplan für bündnisse
demokratischer staaten
jetzt ist es ihr vorschlag für die
zukunft über den auch der g 7 gipfel
hier beraten wird die schöne landschaft
an der küste cornwalls soll die anderen
wohl zum mitmachen anregen bei einer
gerechteren wirtschafts und
handelspolitik beim kampf gegen
klimawandel und pandemie schon kurz nach
seiner ankunft hatte joe biden sein
wichtigstes ziel für den anstehenden
gipfel dargelegt einigkeit der
wirtschaftsnationen unter führung der
usa um dann so versprach er vor
amerikanischen und britischen soldaten
gemeinsam autoritären regimen wie
russland und china die stirn zu bieten
wir müssen jene diskreditieren die
glauben dass das zeitalter der
demokratie vorbei ist wir müssen die
lüge entlarven das dekrete von
diktatoren den herausforderungen des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts
gewachsen joe biden spricht gern klare
worte auch gegenüber verbündeten
ob die beiden sich gestritten haben
wegen doch irland ist offiziell nicht zu
erfahren
in den bayerischen alpen ist ein lange
verschwundene ureinwohner zurück der
bartgeier einer der imposantesten vögel
der welt er liebt hohe berge und tote
tiere der aasfresser stand lange zu
unrecht im verdacht lämmer und sogar
kleine kinder zu rauben
auch deshalb wurde er im neunzehnten
jahrhundert in deutschland erbarmungslos
gejagt jetzt sollen sich zwei jungvögel
bei berchtesgaden zu hause fühlen petra
neubauer
aller anfang ist mühsam
noch sind die beiden bad guy mädchen
wally und bavaria flugunfähig und werden
in kisten auf dem rücken von menschen
hinauf auf das knittel horn gebracht
eine 20 meter breite eingezäunte
auswilderung / ist nun ihr übergangs zu
hause sie sollen zu nehmen
sie sollen vollständig auswachsen und
dann etwa 3-4 wochen ausfliegen
die garküchen stammen aus einer
spanischen nachzucht mit ihren gut 90
tagen sind sie sehr jung doch genau das
ist wichtig für eine erfolgreiche
wiederansiedlung aromen in die region
zurück wo sie ausgewählt ausgeflogen
sind sprich ausgebildet und nächsten
dann hoffentlich da mal in der region
hier in den nationalpark berchtesgaden
sollen die weibchen ihre brut partner
locken denn hier gelten die bedingungen
für bartgeier als ideal
und dazu ist der nationalbank noch auf
weite fläche einfach jagd freies gebiet
die gämsen die steinberger können an
altersschwäche sterben deswegen seit
viele knochen herum und knochen sind
nunmal bad gams leibspeise nach wally
und bavaria soll nun jedes jahr weitere
jungtiere ausgewildert werden in der
hoffnung dass die majestätischen vögel
irgendwann wieder zum typischen bild der
bayerischen alpen gehören
wally und bavaria ja morgen ist es
endlich soweit start der fußball-em und
das weiß auch die kanzlerin angela
merkel wird sich in diesen minuten per
video schalte im deutschen em-quartier
in herzogenaurach an die spieler werden
und die mannschaft einstimmen
schließlich geht es ja gleich im ersten
spiel des dfb teams am dienstag gegen
weltmeister frankreich
es ist ein entspannter nachmittag der
sicherheitsdienst hat sogar zeit sichern
blümchen zu pflücken
thomas müller ist mit dem radl da und
leon goretzka mit einem gesunden
oberschenkel muskelverletzung auskuriert
damit sind alle 26 spieler anwesend viel
getestet und geübt jetzt gilt aber
grundsätzlich sollte unser anspruch
immer sein dass wir liefern und eine
deutsche nationalmannschaft muss
eigentlich immer auch liefern diese
mannschaft wird noch stärker in 22 und
24 aber unser ziel ist schon auch jetzt
schon zu liefern
jetzt muss löw nur noch einen matchplan
liefern das frankreich spiel wird live
im zdf übertragen
in zweien sie man gut oder sogar besser
der chef des deutschen olympischen
sportbundes alfons hörmann und das
präsidium wollen sich nach den
sommerspielen in tokio einer
vertrauensabstimmung stellen und folgen
damit der empfehlung der die usb
ethikkommission
hintergrund ist die verbandsinterne
kritik am führungsstil des präsidenten
und des präsidiums zur hockey em in
amsterdam da standen sich heute
nachmittag im ersten halbfinalspiel der
männer deutschland und england gegenüber
die dhb auswahl gewann knapp aber
verdient mit 3 2
den schönsten treffer dieser partie
erzielte niklas bellen ein tor dass das
spiel gegen england sind seiner gänze
bestens beschreibt denn die deutsche
mannschaft zeit gegen den weltranglisten
sechsten eine starke vorstellung
nach neun minuten bereits eine 2 2
1-führung erzielte strafecken von hannah
und zwicker in der 13 minute fällt dann
das eingangs gezeigte 3 zu 1 1 konter
durch wellen sein fünftes tor in diesem
turnier nach der pause gelingt englands
nach einer strafecke nur noch der
anschluss durch zum mord durch den
erfolg steht deutschland erstmalig seit
2015 wieder in einem em finale und
spielt am samstag gegen die niederlande
oder belgien finnland
morgen sind wir die ganz heftigen
gewitter los es wird fast überall so
nicht die details hat gleich katja
hornuf claus kleber freut sich auf sie
im heute journal um viertel vor zehn und
hier übernimmt morgen christian sievers
danke fehlen presse ich wünsche ihnen
noch einen richtig schönen abend und
sagt auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
meine damen und herren es ist ja so ein
bisschen verhext gerade gehen die
gewitter zu ende da kommt ein neues hoch
und dann schon die nächste kaltfront die
streift uns morgen abend schon an der
nordseeküste
einige von ihnen werden also tiefere
temperaturen haben am wochenende jetzt
aber gucken wir uns erstmal die gewitter
an die zogen heute nämlich endlich mal
blieben nicht so ort fest die zug
richtung war meist süd oder südost auch
jetzt am abend sind noch gewitter
unterwegs in der nacht aber dann
eigentlich nur noch hier in ostbayern
sonst ist es häufig klar bei
temperaturen von 16 bis 9 grad und der
freitag wird sehr freundlich legen
schauer bleiben doch die absolute
ausnahme und einzigen aus bayern kann es
auch mal gewitter die temperaturen
liegen morgens zwischen 22 grad an der
nordsee und bis zu 29 grad am oberrhein
und am samstag müssen wir uns dann im
nordosten auf etwas regen einstellen
danach aber wird es sehr sommerlich am
montag steigen die temperaturen bis 30
grad schön ab noch